hello and welcome to this video playing
a blitz game here on D chess against
shine offer
what is that shine offer German shine
offer set how do we translate that to
English
it's not a step pseudo sacrifice is that
the right translation don't know it's a
sacrifice but it's not really a
sacrifice that is what it means
okay so we got em zürich variation of
the news oh here
and let's see what an offer is doing
yeah white has a wide range of moves
this is one of them a good one
let's see what he does yeah pologize for
the late release of this video here on
the Sunday really recording it on the
day of the release I usually try to
record the video videos before and then
yeah pre-scheduled them for release but
it was just not possible to record on
Saturday for me because I had him that
was not very intelligent probably Shoop
to be two and now he's got yeah it's
probably probably still okay yes so I'm
not really liking this all that much
what I did here um I had had a bit of a
bit of a health issue I was having
muesli I think this is really in words
that can be used in English I was having
muesli and somehow one of those pieces
of grain that got stuck in my throat was
kind of weird and I had to cut really
hard and my voice was totally off yeah
after that and it's still a little bit a
little bit so on my throat in any case I
couldn't do a pre-recorded video so this
is a little bit late yeah I'm not so
happy yeah yeah I think yeah yeah it's
definitely problem Korea should have
played 95 before
yeah white is definitely at least a bit
better here maybe more than a bit
it can take on a 8i sorry I didn't pay
close enough attention him
when
story kind of directed me it seems okay
so now he takes if I go can I go Queen
f6 maybe a set an option
mmm Matt doesn't does it help
and if I take
[Music]
you
that's silly really silly a really silly
plane on my end
hmm I'm just a born down for basically
nothing hmm pretty awful
that's a bit of an odd move but
what is of course - a lot better
the issue is not just the porn of course
but he also has a fairly strong Bishop
power
[Music]
maybe I can
to locate this on the light squares that
is the only small hope but it's really
in just a small hope
to e6 something like that would be good
check c5
yeah it's a very bad position and this
this is a little bit helpful b6 was
stronger
but it's still very bad it's just I
cannot ignore the fact that it's just a
pawn a pawn is a pawn is a pawn
unfortunately
you
yeah if I get like the e7 light to e6 or
something that would be helpful he wants
to go to b3 it seems make sense
you
but then and then I could actually pin
till end well not win we can always hope
move like bishop each form is probably
quite good
but she did not play
oopsie - Mamie
the efficiency tool would be would be
good I guess yeah it's not what I wanted
when he's taking quite a while sugar is
totally wrong with beef arm I think
young
he wants to play you for I guess
[Music]
just off would be awfully bad position
you
annyeong I think I think he could have
played better but it's so bad for me
very bad
but at least it doesn't have the bishop
a anymore and there is a very slight
hope form or blockade but just very
slight 995 m will probably do the trick
Oh
you
okay wow he's playing this enormous he
barely
even okay
knowing better
probably still wrong
mm probably still a draw bit of a shame
okay
mmm Yemenite is somewhat dominated
can shuffle of it
that's still not possible to win this
position I guess
you
a Czech age 3 they seized in a box there
and I cannot promote it so I have to at
the best possible moment get to UM get
to the pawn some Knight to e4 maybe
oh really okay
it probably does
I lose on time okay
yeah weenie with black is kind of funny
I entered the game in a totally lost
ending and he managed to somehow yeah
give this away I'm not quite sure why
and how yeah my main problem was that I
was playing this this here really badly
I thought I'm worse but not much and
rook 88 is probably a bad idea maybe 95
and you can argue probably about the
here I wasn't actually Bishop g6 is
already a bit of a from sorry a bit of a
stupid move because I'm pushing him
towards b2 which is something that makes
no sense the Queen wants to go there
anyway and for example if I play like
this it is better because then Queen B -
I have this additional option when in
order to preserve the bishop he would
have to go to e1 which is really not
very harmonious and this keeps my
options open if I play this of course
and white is a little bit better but
this is just what this opening is yeah
white is a little bit better than but
here I'm getting into some some trouble
because now he is ready to preserve the
bishop in a more comfortable way and
after this and then before I'm a little
bit that's already awkward but now I'm
just giving away upon down essentially
for for no compensation and here b5 was
even stronger even though this is good
yeah I mean this is a winning ending
nothing more nothing less
yeah but here here there are a couple of
things that can be mentioned in terms of
technical play I think that I mean white
will be better basically no matter what
but just in terms of how to play this
from a technical point of view why
shouldn't play F 4 because that gives me
sly
it's very slight hope for blockade under
light squares I would rather play with
f3 and potentially e4 in this position
like what the engine suggests here f3
let us say a for game I mean f3 pulled
on light squares yeah this is not so
great
technically speaking but I mean white is
so much better that it is it's not yet a
relevant problem because he has such a
such a huge advantage here I was
thinking b6 but again it's it's very
it's very much better for wide and here
we name makes mistakes later it is still
something that white should win he got
an F for which was good yeah here this
looks excellent ready for white 55 yeah
now somewhere around here I was getting
a little bit a little bit of hope that
you could maybe he would at least them
with some with some luck lots of luck
yeah Knight c4 Knight bag age 595
yeah 95 I'm not not sure if that is best
the computer wants to kill g5 and then
95
okay look what this F 500 them this is
very very bad
Oobleck yes till this should be enough
but no it's it's already a draw
okay that's it surprising
I mean I thought it helped me but I
didn't think it is a draw
so it takes takes and 97 is already a
draw
Wow and makes an often set dollar
Cynthia once you look at it it looks at
both points so that the King cannot go
over to the Kings side for example here
I mean if I get here I'm fine
quite clearly and he cannot go Kingi for
me I'm just taking this with check and
that is a drawing what I think even more
precise as King e61 let the King in
there that is a draw okay I played 95
which was was bad then yeah King e4
looks very normal here Keaney form
still think this should be enough
No yeah now this was very weird that he
allowed me to play King f5 after King
afore I still think I should be in great
danger
I'm not certain that that this is a
fortress
probably not
it is the right bishopman it's a dark
squared bishop for this corner
the engine still thinks I'm lost
I think aged form
now if he gets if he gets h5 I should be
lost
I hit four kings you form
okay I get both parts actually
for ready for take take Nathan tear this
I should draw huh but that was strange
after this move I'm definitely out of
the woods and now he didn't find some
emergency exit some some way out
106 and now here you have to drop a this
make sure to get to the pond yeah here
things are critical I'm not certain I'm
winning I rather believe it's still
wrong
I hate bishops his seven was a draw
already so the engines has set wins
really okay
can I stop you fool
how do you win how do you win this
position
and I don't see it I mean when we look
at the game I got here I I don't don't
see how I'm winning
and I don't see it really
here and I don't think I mean if I have
to like run over here to gain this pawn
and right get CH porn that is a draw I
believe it's a draw still really
yeah yeah it's a bit of a a bit of a
joke that I wonder came here from that
bad position but what can I do we have
to accept some gifts sometimes ok guys
thanks for watching